let's get the top photos here on a
Thursday a job Thursday yeah all right
well number three while the TSA missed
about 95% of explosives and weapons
during recent undercover security tests
it certainly doesn't select cold hard
cash go by unnoticed
Lisa barb sign is in deep Twitter
trouble after tweeting this photo of
passengers bag it has $75,000 in it look
about some interceptive so I was
wondering about this and both 10,000 is
illegal but only if you're traveling
internationally apparently you can can
you can apparently carry anything usual
the 2,000 I took in a suitcase I hope
that was a carry-on check that kind of
bag you probably paid extra for it don't
worry number two in Beverly Hills
California PETA demonstrators protests
the killing of reptiles outside an
Hermes storm one woman pictured here
wore a crocodile skin jumpsuit while
others held signs that red bag the cruel
crocodile skin and three animals killed
for one bag it's the famous Birkin bag
of course III imagine that's not a real
but but Python and all that's very big
right or real but it's always big isn't
it yeah I think I saw a Python dress
having about 8,500 leopards good and Tom
I think that would through you know I
know it's just they're taking it from
fur over to I mean I don't have a strong
opinion on this other than I guess
that's what it is and they're doing it
well yams well certainly very graphic
about us number one in Mexico artist
Dalton Ramirez created a Donald Trump
pinata complete with his signature quoi
the artist design yeah I quote because
of the haters the hatred Trump expressed
for the Mexican people
this is consumed right I mean yeah the
main story is this was not a one-off
no this is really good and he's
threatening to sue univisio enough we're
pulling the Miss Universe everybody and
everybody is pulling out nobody wants to
be associated New York exactly everybody
pulling out but he's very litigious
Trump he's known for his yeah